Німеччина - одна з найбільш багатих на ліси країн Європи.
Понад 30 відсотків території вкрито лісами.
Найбільше у Баварії та Гессені.
Сюжети багатьох казок братів Грімм відбуваються саме в гессенських дрімучих лісах.
Те, як у Німеччині дбають про ліси, - приклад для багатьох інших країн.
Німці навіть примудрилися порахувати всі свої дерева.
За даними останньої інвентаризації лісів,
у ФРН нині приблизно 90 мільярдів дерев.
Майже половина усіх лісів Німеччини,
а саме 48 відсотків - у приватній власності.
Це різноманітні фонди, церковні та інші організації, фірми, а також фізичні особи.
Загалом близько двох мільйонів власників лісових угідь.
Середня площа приватних лісових володінь - три гектари,
а у лісозаготівельних підприємств - від 20 до 200 га.
Ліс і деревина у Німеччині - потужний сектор економіки,
який створює понад мільйон робочих місць
і має щорічний оборот
приблизно 170-180 мільярдів євро.
У Німеччині щорічно вирубують 76 мільйонів кубометрів лісу,
але при цьому щорічно відростає значно більше -
122 мільйони кубів лісу.
Скільки дерев можна вирубати в кожному конкретному лісі,
вирішує так званий "лісовий розпорядник".
Він перевіряє і контролює різноманіття видів, вік дерев,
зростання і запас лісових ресурсів.
Усі ці дані ретельно фіксуються, щоб можна було простежити,
як остання вирубка вплинула на ліс
Раніше практикували суцільні вирубки.
Нині ж це роблять здебільшого після буреломів, під час посух
чи через захворювання великих масивів дерев,
щоб зараження не поширювалося далі.
Зараз, як правило, вирубують дерева саме вибірково.
Через це в лісах виникають сонячні прогалини,
старі дерева ростуть разом з молодими,
а шляхом вибіркової підтримки слабших видів дерев
вдається покращити лісову різноманітність.
Перш ніж зрубати дерево на приватній території,
навіть якщо вона належить вам особисто,
слід отримати дозвіл у місцевих органів влади.
Саме вони визначають умови,
за яких можна це зробити,
і перевіряють, чи це дерево не під охороною.
Штрафи за незаконну вирубку дерев можуть сягати сотень тисяч євро.
Половина усіх німецьких лісів - це ялиці і сосни.
Буків - 16 відсотків, а дубів - 11.
Хвойні дерева переважали не завжди.
Раніше навпаки було більше листяних лісів.
Але в середні віки і наступні епохи багато листяних масивів
були вирубані або сильно виснажені.
І в Німеччині довгий час вважали, що на місці зрубаних листяних дерев
краще саджати хвойні породи, які швидко ростуть.
Нині ж уже декілька останніх десятиліть
німці реорганізують свої ліси, поступово замінюючи хвойні на змішані ліси.
Головний принцип - не те, що потрібно людям, а те, що потрібно природі.
Це також допомагає боротися з екологічними катастрофами та зміною клімату.
Адже нові змішані ліси, що виникають на місці старих хвойних,
відрізняються більшою стійкістю проти негоди, посухи і хвороб.
У деяких федеральних землях заборонено паління в лісах з березня по жовтень,
а у багатьох - навіть цілий рік.
Розміри штрафів за куріння та розведення вогню в лісі
регулюються місцевою владою.
Як правило, від 80 до 100 євро.
Іноді 20 євро або усне попередження.
Якщо ж виникнуть якісь обтяжуючі обставини,
то штраф може бути і 50 тисяч євро.
У Берліні, приміром, розмір штрафу залежить, зокрема, від погодних умов:
чим сухіша погода, тим вищий штраф.
Влада завчасно попереджає про підвищену небезпеку пожеж у лісах.
Часто застереження траснслюють у прогнозах погоди.
Збирати ягоди, гриби, горіхи, трави і квіти,
якщо вони не знаходяться під захистом, дозволено,
втім лише у невеликих кількостях і лише для особистих потреб.
Це означає: по одній-дві порції грибів на кожного, хто збирає,
максимум - два кілограми в день.
Якщо хочеться набрати більше, щоб, приміром, пригостити сусідів,
потрібно попередньо отримати спеціальний дозвіл.
А щодо квітів та інших рослин діє просте правило:
не більше одного маленького букета, який може поміститися
між складеними в кільце великим і вказівним пальцями руки.
У деяких федеральних землях вигулювати собак у лісі можна тільки на повідку.
На пікніки збиратися у лісі можна.
Головна умова - прибирати за собою сміття.
Якщо ви цього не зробили і вага сміття перевищує два кілограми,
то штраф може сягати 500 євро.
Німці дбайливо ставляться до своїх лісів,
керуючись принципом тривалого і невичерпного використання.
У Німеччині понад 8 тисяч різноманітних природоохоронних зон і територій,
а також 13 лісових національних парків,
серед яких найбільш відомі Шварцвальд і Баварський ліс.
Крім того, є 5 прадавніхбукових лісів,
внесених у список Всесвітньої спадщини ЮНЕСКО.